hi there steve kaufman here um
back from skiing with uh the kids and
grandchildren and so forth
um
i want to talk today about what it is
possible to achieve in three months
in in terms of language learning
uh with specific reference to chinese
and i'm going to do this for two reasons
first of all because uh
one of my regular viewers icelandic i
think his name is asked me how difficult
chinese is and also because it was
brought to my attention uh at a thread
at our forum at link
that benny lewis has announced that he
is going to become fluent in chinese in
three months
so uh let's first of all look at at
benny lewis's claim
uh he has a video which uh i think i'll
post the link here
uh at any rate uh links sometimes don't
work here at youtube i don't know why
you can also google him and you'll find
it
uh he points out that uh you know in the
european framework system of of grading
uh you know proficiency in in languages
c1 corresponds to sort of a
advanced one in other words c2 is
complete mastery
of everything the able the ability to be
you know as subtle almost as a native
speaker and in in expressing yourself
and so forth and so on
uh c1 is just one level below that and
he claims that he'll reach that in three
months in chinese
uh now right off the bat let's make it
very clear that that is pure nonsense
uh he will not achieve that level in
three months
uh he will be able to achieve a level of
being able to converse on simple
subjects in chinese
uh he says that he
will be able to read headlines in a
newspaper not necessarily because
headlines may contain characters that he
doesn't know i think it's possible for
him to have a thousand characters after
three months maybe a few more
uh and so that'll give him some sense of
um
of what these articles are about
um now just to
talk a little more about benny benny is
is his approach is that he he is uh he
claims to travel the world spend three
months in different places and
spend uh you know maybe an initial a few
hours or a day going over some language
book and then throwing that away and
just going out and talking to people and
that way he becomes fluent in three
months which i consider to be nonsense
uh he has not demonstrated the ability
to do that those languages that he
speaks well he spent an awful lot longer
than three months at
and where he has gone to places like
thailand
prague
budapest
um with the idea of uh becoming fluent
by just talking to people he hasn't
achieved that so um he won't succeed
however let's look at this issue of a
what is fluence well first of all what
can you do or how long does it take to
get to fluency all right
you can you can check up under wikipedia
you can see what the foreign service
institute in the united states says it
takes
my own view is that if you're willing to
and i think in language learning it
almost doesn't matter what you do
you have to be motivated the three
things as i always say motivation
time with the language
and developing the ability to notice
those are the three things that are
going to let you achieve
um proficiency
now time
uh in the case of most european
languages that contain have a lot of
overlapping vocabulary with english that
don't are have too many difficult cases
and so forth to deal with i think that
you can achieve a lot in three months i
think you can be quite comfortable
speaking after three months if you're in
the country if you're working at it like
10 hours a day
and therefore developing this ability to
notice noticing the sounds noting
noticing the structures you can be quite
comfortable after three months
the slavic languages i think you need
longer is it five months six months i
don't know but longer
again on the assumption that you're in
the country that you're very motivated
that you're basically devoting yourself
in other words you're not there with
your spouse who speaks english you're
not having to work in english you
basically are devoting yourself
to learning the language that i can i
think you can achieve a lot
however with chinese it's a little more
difficult because and particularly if
you follow benny's approach which is to
throw away the book after a short while
and just go out and talk to people
you're not going to learn characters
that way i don't think you can
accumulate a lot of vocabulary that way
either i happen to believe and that's
the way we built link that it takes a
lot of deliberate listening reading
and deliberate vocabulary accumulation
to build up enough words so that you
understand what people are saying
because if you don't understand what
people are saying you can't really
communicate with them
then he has a different approach fine he
goes out and talks to people he probably
spends a lot more time listening
because he hasn't got much to say in the
beginning but that's not going to get
you to the number of characters you need
in order to be able to read and reading
is important as a means of developing
vocabulary and to have a comfortable
conversation on a variety of subjects
which is what c1 implies
you have to have a large vocabulary so
for those reasons three
three months to see one it's simply not
gonna happen he will achieve perhaps b1
if he works very hard if he works very
hard
uh and i know from my own experience
that within three months i was reading
the newspaper looking up a lot of words
fighting my way through these newspaper
articles and i was able to converse in
simple terms and i see no reason why
benny couldn't achieve in three months
what i achieved in three months
in fact he might do better he's younger
well no i was younger then but he's in
taiwan i was in hong kong so he's
surrounded by the language so yeah i
think he can achieve b1 i think that's
realistic
um
to develop a sort of to get to a c1
level i think nine to 12 months is going
flat out like i did
uh
three hours a day of class and then
basically i just studied the whole time
i went out to dinner and went back home
and studied uh if i went to the movies
that i didn't like the movie i was gonna
take a break i went with my girlfriend
who became my wife we went out and if i
didn't like the movie after 20 minutes i
went home to study like i was completely
fanatic completely fanatic which i think
is very good in language learning
because the more intensely you do it the
faster you learn the more you can focus
on it the quicker you're you're changing
your brain around to
becoming comfortable in this new in this
little new language and the more things
you start to notice
so you know motivation time and the
ability to notice
um what else was i going to say yeah
then he talked a little bit about
the fact that um
when he explained that he was going for
c1 which is only you know one step below
c2
the european framework a1 a1 is beginner
a1 a2 b1 d2 which is intermediate 1 and
2 and then c1 c2 is advanced one
advanced two so he wasn't going to quite
reach c2 he was only going to reach cy
in matter which of course he's not going
to do
now he says however that in french and
spanish he's at c2 i don't believe that
either
because c2 is a very high level of
competence and while i've heard benny
speak french and spanish and he says i'm
at c2 in french and spanish and a few
other languages which he doesn't name so
i can only assume that he's not
as good in those languages as he claims
to be in french and spanish he speaks
very well french and spanish but it's
not c2 and we needn't you know make
these unrealistic demands of ourselves
it's enough to say to me it seems i
speak it well i speak french well
uh but i'm not mistaken for a form for a
native i'm not mistaken for a native
again i don't understand why benny makes
these claims that in you know he went to
germany to be mistaken for berliner
after three months or he went to brazil
to be mistaken for a native karaoke and
of course he isn't because
the
portuguese brazilian portuguese that you
can hear on his site i had people at uh
at irelias brazilians coming on and they
say uh he sounds a bit like a caricature
of brazilian or he sounds like a gringo
these are their comments he doesn't
sound like a native speaker and you
don't need to sound like a native
speaker so i i i guess where i come with
ben is i don't understand why he
continues to make these outlandish
claims
where he's consistently falls down and
doesn't deliver on them
it's enough to say
you know the positive part of his
message is that here's this guy that
loves learning languages travels the
world encourages people to get up and
speak don't feel bashful you know don't
worry about making mistakes all of those
are positive messages but to suggest
that anyone in three months is going to
reach c2 c1 rather you know an advanced
level in chinese
uh it just ain't gonna happen
um
chinese is more difficult and again just
take a few more minutes here on
difficulty what makes languages
difficult
number one the more vocabulary in common
with your own language the easier it's
going to be because the big task to me
in language learning is acquiring words
so that you can understand
what you read
and hear and the more you understand the
more words you have the more you can
learn incidentally because you can you
know you get a sense for more and more
of the context of what you're hearing
and noticing words and noticing
everything is a matter of
having more of it
familiar so that the few things that
stick up now you can notice i notice you
know patterns in russian that i didn't
notice six months ago so familiarity of
the language similarity to your own in
terms of vocabulary number two
is
you know inflected languages are more
difficult inflected languages are
languages where the word endings change
a lot and those are generally more
difficult for people
who speak languages that are not
inflected like english it's more
difficult
more
you know
different forms of the word to learn now
chinese is not an inflected language and
so that makes chinese easier however
chinese has a few other problems chinese
essentially is not written phonetically
although there is a phonetic system to
help you learn how to pronounce the
words
but it's written in characters so you
have to learn these characters
3 000 characters minimum in order to be
had be able to read the newspaper and
have enough vocabulary to converse
seriously with people
um so the characters then you have the
tones which is different and and what it
means is not only that you have to learn
the four tones and learn to hear them
and and and then eventually to pronounce
them
a lot of the words sound the same
because they are the same sound they may
even be the same sound and the same tone
there are a lot of homonyms in chinese
and that makes it more difficult to
understand
so comprehension becomes more difficult
um
so
a non-phonetic script lots of characters
to learn
um
lots of homonyms tones and then of
course the vocabulary is all new
unless you happen to be say a japanese
speaker in which case there will be a
lot of vocabulary that you will start to
recognize in chinese and you'll also
recognize the characters but if you are
a speaker of a european language all the
vocabulary is new
the compensating factors in chinese are
that the grammar is extremely
straightforward the words don't change
uh tenses are very straightforward and
that the vocabulary builds quite
logically so once you have
enough characters
because the word in terms of what we
consider a word in english consists
often of two or three characters if you
see different combinations of characters
you can kind of figure out what the word
means or at least it's easy to remember
so vocabulary accumulation
uh
becomes a little easier in chinese once
you have enough characters
but nevertheless chinese fall out full
bore to get the c1 you're looking at a
year realistically under absolute ideal
conditions
um
yeah what else was i going to say that's
about it so and i wanted to make this
point because i think it's misleading to
people to suggest that there are people
out there who achieve
fluency in chinese in three months they
don't
it's uh
and most people also don't have the
luxury of traveling to the country if
you do live in the country
obviously it's a big advantage and
obviously you're going to try and speak
as soon as you can and as often as you
can and so forth but it's not realistic
to suggest that even in those conditions
that people are going to want to speak
to you uh if you can't speak i mean if
someone came up to me and babbled to me
and something that was hardly
recognizable as english i mean how much
time am i going to spend with that
person
so therefore again i say it's far more
realistic to realize that you have to do
a lot of you have to do a lot of work on
your own
you have to do a lot of listening and
reading on your own you have to work on
your vocabulary and slowly go out there
and start using it where you have the
opportunity and for the vast majority of
people who aren't in the country where
the language is spoken
you have to do even more on your own and
then find opportunities via skype and so
forth
to speak the language as soon as you
start to feel confident so there you
have it
uh some discussion of the subject of
what you can achieve in three months how
long it
takes to achieve fluency in different
languages and again
ending up with the the key to language
learning which is the three the three
key elements your own motivation and
being in the country can be very
motivating the amount of time you have
available and if you have a full day to
devote to language learning you can move
quite quickly in a language and third of
all developing that ability to notice
and beyond that
there are no hacks it's the language
it's hearing it it's
it's reading it it's speaking it it's
writing it and it's spending that time
with the language
and and keeping an open mind and being
flexible
thank you for listening bye for now